in this video you're gonna see a little
bit of reckless being around a lot of
people without masks on okay so we're
back from the trip and I'm getting a
test
luckily my tests came back negative and
now I'm being very very careful and I
hope you all are too oh it's time to
properly introduce you guys to our
bitchin studio van which I call Ruby and
to do that we went on the most epic road
trip from Los Angeles to Albuquerque New
Mexico to get totally rad with a bunch
of UFC legends do some [ __ ] and stunts
and most importantly live in this
[ __ ] thing with international stars
Scott Randall yeah so we headed out of
Los Angeles
that's it and we went to Phoenix first
stop to catch up with our buddy JP the
shady prop guy from jackass and he says
do did you bring their skateboard
there's a skateboarders protest against
police brutality and I was like let's do
it so we spent the night in Phoenix and
the next day we headed to Flagstaff
Arizona we got to Flagstaff and we set
up camp in this [ __ ] in National Forest
why cuz we're stuck yeah dude that was
just a rad spot man that was the first
time that we lowered the bunk bed for
Scott to sleep in here how'd you sleep
Scott I was doing pretty good until I
smelled [ __ ] somewhere and I couldn't
figure out where it's coming from I
wasn't even gonna admit this but yeah
Wendy had diarrhea [ __ ] place right in
the seat that you're sitting in but we
got it cleaned up by the Detailers and
then we [ __ ] pressed on to Albuquerque
New Mexico so we get to Albuquerque and
I'm like man there's this apartment
building that I did a three-story front
flip into five feet of water like almost
25 years ago I want to check it out so
we went and checked it out and I just
thought well maybe I'll do it I know I
mean I'm not telling you to do it I'm
just saying you can't tease us like that
I climbed up but I'm looking at this
five foot deep pool and I'm 6 feet tall
I'm just like dude on a risk/reward
ratio it's not worth it so I wimped out
climbed it down and it was really
bugging me so we go over to John Jones's
house right away
we're like sticking my ear in a [ __ ]
barbell set and he's
like crazy because I'm trying to get
cauliflower here you know and then she
wants to spar with me I'm getting like
taken down by the light heavyweight
champion of the world it was super
creepy but what an epic night Russell
John John and we woke up the next
morning we go straight to Jackson wing
Academy right this is the training
facility for like MMA legends Holly Holm
might have beat my ass a little bit
[Laughter]
[Music]
legendary lady Holly Holm does one-tenth
of a round so we leave Jackson wing for
Walmart where we bought thousands of
dollars of toiletries socks underwear
towels to give out to people who needed
them in the streets which was pretty
cool
we gave most of these care packages out
at a place called tent city which had a
skate park right there so next thing you
know I'm doing tricks around the skate
park John Jones there and he goes to
grab my board and I'm thinking no no
career-ending injury is gonna be all my
fault
trying to film over here pal but he's
determined so he's riding down the ramps
like
I'm like dude let me jump over you so we
leave the skatepark and we got a few
more care packages to give away we go to
this spot we give away the last one and
out of curiosity I check my phone and I
say to John Jones you know that building
I told you about it's point three miles
away and he's like let's do it so I'm
like oh god now there's no one but now I
got to do this thing
UFC fighter Maurice Greene filmed me
climbing up into the little thing to get
onto the roof which by the way is
exactly the same way it was 25 years ago
John Jones is flying the drone and did I
was terrified I was honestly terrified
[ __ ] but I had to do it so I did my
trick which has always worked 1 2 3 go
and I've never backed out when I count 1
2 3 go
oh that feels really good
yeah we pulled it and then the
professional photographer he tells me
that he shot a sequence and it's gonna
be this one frame photo sequence and I'm
like oh my god we came here to help
people in Albuquerque that was the whole
point of the trip so let me make prints
and sign every single one of them and
sell them to raise money for the
Albuquerque Food Bank
it's called Roadrunner Food Bank of New
Mexico man it's really important because
New Mexico is the number one state for
children food and security that's where
the most children don't know where their
next meal is coming from
that's just sad so please go to my
website click building jump print every
signature looks like a penis and it's a
good thing that we really feel good
about then we went back to John John's
house and in his championship belt room
featuring every fight poster which he
calls victim Hall I got to show John
Jones and his boys my new project which
is a multimedia comedy special featuring
the entire cast of Jackass doing gnarly
stuff I'm at such an exciting time and
I'd like to do some more like kind of
vlog stuff like this on the podcast
channel and please support the podcast
too man it's cool if you have any guests
that you want to see just put it in the
comment section dude yeah cool man